yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby
let's go it's going oh we're rolling
already already now now now shits and
gigs sh and G and gigs yes sir [__] and
gigs I love it the boys are here man all
the way across from the pond what
brought you to uh Cali this we doing a
little run um with potentially nothing
solidified we're potentially going to do
a little tour here next year now when
you walk down the street in West
Hollywood are you getting recognized now
and again not as bad as in London as bad
as London you guys are Tom Cruz in
London you guys are massive you guys are
big you guys are big appr you boys are
crushing it man I'm I'm a fan I was
howling it's tough to make me laugh on a
pod dude [__] I tell he called me bro
we got to take a page cuz this is how we
start you're like us man like dude when
when you guys were talking about when
people are calling in they sent you
things to talk about and they're talking
about worst things someone's ever said
to them oh my God BR brutal General
Republic are
brutalo it was so so and you talking
about where where they were talking
about fancy ways to say you're ugly yes
that was my favorite we take our
bloodline very
seriously you don't have the Symmetry
that's needed [__] my favorite was it
was like coming from an outsider yeah
yeah pretty
privilege outsid perspective hilarious
now you're you're Nigerian by by
ethnicity is is there pressure from your
family yeah cuz you usually if you're
going to step outside the Nigerian even
the euroba clan you're going to have
some you're going to take some [__] yeah
so I think it's different for me because
I was born and bred in the UK I was
supposed to born and raised in I could
tell then moved to the UK then but there
was a bit more pressure when I was young
especially cuz I have an older sister
and she's more intellectual than me and
she went through like the um not
necessarily engineering but she went
through a smarter route than me she went
to a better uni than me she got more
better grades than me you know so it was
more of like a comparison thing but as
soon as as soon as I said I'm going to
leave my job to start doing this
full-time they're like just make sure
you're sure you know just make sure
you're sure it's going to work but I've
got faith in you but just make sure sure
but now they're cool now they
right yeah take them to dinners
when did you and when did you guys know
to kind of quit the 9 to5 UM for me
personally I quit way before we could
afford to yeah yeah yeah yeah we had
like a set we like when when stuff
started to cook and we were getting
better and bigger we had like a
whiteboard in our in our office and we
like cool if we're making this much we
can go part-time if we go this much we
can make fulltime I don't even think we
reached the part-time thing and I was
working this is during uh like lockdown
and everyone was working from home and
I'd set up an office in my mom's house
and I was like every day like I'm going
to kill myself I can't do this anymore
like [__] this job I actually can't
handle it anymore um so yeah being in a
cubicle yeah it was crazy my nephew just
called me said this he goes I'm working
in a cub yeah that bro he goes I can't I
go exactly you got to find your plan
your Escape now I was dying so yeah one
day I was just like all right cool I
just rang my BS and was like dude I'm
sorry like it's but I was watching you
guys podcasts the beautiful thing is
that you guys just like us would be
doing that [__] together in a bar or in
a parking lot say you know what I'm
what's that say Pub though Pub apologize
you know you know his mom is British so
we got I in the house but and now people
can hear you guys just be well basically
tell dick Jokes which is what we do we
haven't got a p we've done over a
thousand episodes I don't think we've
gone uh one episode and I'm being
serious without alluding to the fact
that we're both gay men and talking
about a reference of a wiener here's the
difference know he's 56 all right well
take it easy I got tight fit and skin
give their fans a second to take this
in you see that you see I saw something
you saw and you saw way you saw my body
you saw you cuz you you looked at me and
you went like that a little bit Yeah cuz
it's like um when you see someone so
malnourished in such
a no I thought he was doing better how's
he not no no no no I thought I thought
you were like do you play football not
not the American kind yeah like you'd be
like a decent goalkeeper eses yeah on
down
days first Cho for the rec league guy
the guy who stands there while you try
to hit him with the ball yeah yeah
exactly you're cutting orange slices for
the kids [__] this
podcast you give it a little bit of a a
UK Drake Vibe right I get all you get
that all the time it's worse now because
was obviously getting recognized more
when when we were younger I would get it
like all the time but now people come up
to me like oh my God then I'm just like
oh here we go yeah yeah it's that I mean
it's not terrible now they're
recognizing you for you exactly but then
you get confused cuz sometimes they rush
over like oh my God oh my God I'm like
yeah yeah yeah I'm him and they're like
you look so much like Drake and I'm like
[__] um he's not Terri it's not like
he's you know hideous he's not hideous
but he's not like if we're talking
objective looks like he's not Jason M
yeah exactly yeah is a man he's a real
man yeah I'm top of my list he's better
looking than Drake Thank you very much
okay damn hot hot the first thing I said
too like damn and you guys Drake meter
just had red hot this bad boy and are
you guys you guys have ladies or are you
both single we have ladies have ladies
yeah yeah we have ladies yeah I love
that I love I love young man we got
ladies I mean yeah I mean I'm in that
acoss the ocean all be cool very cool
that question for every dude is I don't
know why it's loaded it's like you're
married
yeah you got a you got a girl like Yeah
man so uh so anyway you guys this is
Studio this studio is
nice are we in casses this is my best
friend in the world I my girl was
pregnant for three months four months
before he even knew I just didn't bring
it up same thing with
him I didn't know your wife's name for
six years W that was embarrassing I was
like what's her uh you're like and this
and then I was like you don't know her
name like
nah yeah we're bad all right let me
still one of these I need some caffeine
I'll get you some man I'm try try one of
these bad boys what's this that's a
magic mind that's where we take every
Everything magic mind it's basically
like um it's like a neutr it's like
energy yeah it's like a neut Tropic but
it's like it basically gets state but
it's all natural it's not like chemicals
and stuff like that okay it's got matcha
more antioxidants you own company why
you talking like this no I just like
even I know he doesn't own it and it's
no I agree it's like a Ponzi scheme I
wish TR man let me know 14.99 I'm really
good friends with the U with the CE CEO
and the reason I trust it is he made all
his money in another industry then he he
drank too much coffee had a heart
condition and had to come up with an
alternative to Coffee W so I know he he
makes it he doesn't have he doesn't have
to make money on it so that's why I
trust you still feel suspect when you
describe it like that a little bit yeah
I feel like you were going to say if you
just give me like five grand now we'll
get you in we you two people below you
we talk I I literally called him cuz
they're coming up with a fizzy an energy
drink and I was like can I get in on the
action here let me get a little so but
no it doesn't taste terrible doesn't
taste terrible all it's good right sweet
la but see if it makes a difference uh
see if I look a little clearer we'll see
was magic mushrooms in
there could get weird fellas bro bro I
took magic mushrooms we did Rogan we do
this fight companion yeah I love the
fight compion we watch and I took I I
got some he gave me some chocolate you
know but I took apparently you asked for
it yeah because you guys were [__]
drinking smoking weed which I don't want
to do at 11: in the morning so I go well
let me try some mushrooms take the edge
off it'll be fun I'm not a season
Tripper it that [__] hit me and I
literally in the middle at the end of
the podcast I have to catch a flight I
had two flights I I panicked so I I
leave and then I'm I get on the plane
and I'm having trouble eating my popcorn
I'm I'm I'm having trouble negotiating
my hand and I start eating it oh my God
have you ever had that have you guys
ever done any I've I've done I think
like Edibles is the most we've ever I've
ever done and even then I was like like
[__] like tiny yeah I don't get down
with it either it's not for me so you
guys you there's no way you smoking now
one again in it yeah and you guys have
been friends for how long 14 years 14
years maybe 15 years yeah from the I
mean yeah we met on our first day of uh
University we met he was like the only
other black there was like him and one
other black guy in the in the lecture
and I was like right those are my guys
those are my guys literally that's it
and then we've been friends ever since
and then who's idea was it to start the
Pod it was idea yeah it was my idea so
again working full-time job hated it and
what was the gig um so I used to be a
personal trainer um and then at this
point what was I doing as a job I was
working in like Gym Sales um dude it was
horrific bro yeah it was horrific and
then I just literally needed I was a
super like I'm a massive podcast nerd um
I love podcasts so what we used to
happen he lived in Manchester which is
like 3 hours from me from London so he'
moved there for work so I'd visit him
probably once a month and then every
month would go out get drunk and then
spend the whole next day just on his
couch just shooting the [__] laughing
talking about old stories just like
basically doing a podcast in his living
room every single time and then I said
but you were recording it or you weren't
wer we just having a conversation and
then I said oh bro like I'm not going to
lie I need I can't stay focused on this
job I need hope so even I don't expect
the podcast to go anywhere but I need to
pretend that it can which is going to
get me through this 9 to5 yeah um so we
started it I literally asked him for
like 6 months straight and he was like
no no no no um why did you say no I just
probably not even time cuz I've got time
for my boy always but it's one of those
ones where I didn't feel like I didn't
feel like I wanted my face on screen and
things like that I just and I wasn't
into podcast at the time you know so I
just thought it wasn't going to be my
Avenue but celebrities a liability now
ites it's not like but I don't think
it's celebrity like with with podcast
too it's like everybody does it now like
when we started damn near 13 years ago
it was very rare like when you said
podcast we're like What on the radio
you're like no so even he was cuz he was
a full-time actor at the time and when
he did it his all his actor friends seen
so much [__] they ging so much [__] I'm
like my agent my agent was like what are
you doing
he yeah he was the one I'm telling you
just show up twice a week I'm telling
you it's going you remember when that
was when that moment was when we had
Conor McGregor on yeah we had Conor
McGregor on and we were just sitting
there and we we we got along with him
because we started talking to him you
know when the cameras weren't off right
like dudes and so we're like and so he
kind of trusted us especially him CU he
was a fighter in the UFC before him but
then I remember you just said we just
keep this going and I go CU was kind of
I show I was [__] yeah I you know I
was just and I don't play that game like
it's either you're in or all in or let's
not do the you got to and you guys do it
I listen to your show and it's
consistent people that do it here and
there it's like you're not going to keep
up bro and like I come from TV so with
like ESPN showtime and with sports like
you got to be consistent can't so I told
I tell him any advice I mean straight up
cuz I'd be I'd be on set I'd be in
makeup I would come in my [__] shorts
and makeup my hair I was crazy but but
he was the one who was like if we don't
do it every like consistently we may as
well not do it and I remember I said to
you you we'll keep it going I go what do
you mean you go we just keep doing this
no matter what yeah for sure man and it
it pays off like we always said as well
like when opportunities are given to us
um like our first thought process is
always like does this bother will this
bother me doing it three times a week
every week for the rest of time and will
I still enjoy it or am I thinking H this
is going to piss me off in in like a
couple months I'm not going to want to
do this and if we even have that we're
like no we're not doing uh if we can't
see ourselves doing it consistently
forever then we just rather not even
start cuz it's just a recipe you guys
have guests too don't you like once a
month um we have uh a guest on now and
again um we're trying to do it more
consistently we again I like I like when
it's just you guys yeah most people say
that and that's what that was
intentional as well when we started is
that at the time most like 90% of
podcast even till now we're just doing
like guest orientated stuff and again I
was like I just don't want the hassle of
for one relying on guest always looking
for a bigger guest there's nothing worse
my God take it from me brother when it
comes to like there's
nothing I think it's the worst part of
the game it does but I think it's the
worst part of the game is and I hate
asking people to do things and if it's a
friend and it so it's like when it's
just us that's what it was designed for
and then obviously to grow you got to
get guests but when it's when it's you
two that's that's the special St you
don't want to keep you know that's our
favorite that's why we yeah we only do
guests once a month and if we miss month
it is we don't really care like I think
at the beginning of the year we said
okay let's get a guest every month and I
think this whole year we said that in
January we' already had three guests
three guests this whole
year but that's when you know you're
you're vibing when you just need each
other and you're just bullshitting you
got something to talk about authentic as
well cuz it's not like um we didn't know
each other prior like oh let's start a
podcast together we known each other for
years the conversations we have outside
of the Pod is the stuff we talk about on
the Pod so it's just authentic and easy
I think it shows how talented you guys
are how good it is cuz again this day
and age everyone their gay ant has a
podcast out of their basement and
they're pretty consistent cuz they know
you can make money now so for you guys
to be an outlier in this day and age
like when we started it you know
basically black and white but when you
guys like now to like blow up like you
have yeah well actually yeah that's what
I was going to say like who's your
audience is your audience primarily
young men you think so it's actually 70%
women women what yeah I what say 7 you
guys talk about relationships boy we
couldn't be more different yeah bro cuz
this is a straight [__] F I mean My Demo
is 18 to 45 Bros like that look like me
dude it's very rare we get a lady very
rare we didn't expect it cuz yeah
obviously how we are uh how we interact
you'd expect the audience to just be
100% dudes but then when the numbers
started coming in and then like you see
the demo you're like what but they want
to hear probably how a m man's mind
that's one most of the feedback we get
is starting off they just want to see
how dudes think and that's why they're
interested and then they stay because
it's just it's just Vibes like we don't
like push a lot of podcasts especially
now that's when everyone's talking about
like I take away male podcasters and
don't let them talk and all this kind of
stuff burn their equipment yeah burn
their equipment I think like very very
very similar to you guys like we're a
little bit more like nuanced in our
masculinity like we just talk about like
yeah I talk about like sucking his dick
like all the time that was so funny when
you were like if he got bit on the dick
oh yeah and he's like I mean I'd sucking
twice like that's up my alley be let's
take a little break with the boys these
love these guys man and uh they just
like us but way more handome and darker
I'm gonna be in Chicago this weekend I
don't know if D shamber I'll be in
shamberg improv uh October this Friday
Saturday everybody and then I'm at
Raleigh at good nights November 9 10 and
11 uh in in Raleigh North Carolina and
then Calgary I'm going back to Mama I'm
coming home I'm coming to uh Canada
Calgary been there been about four years
178 b.com for all uh and I am headed
next week I will be in Niagara Falls New
York at senica casino November 3rd and
4th those shows are damn near sold out
uh that is one show Friday one show
Saturday I have the great Brett Forte
with me and then Chicago December 8th
and 9th two shows Friday two shows
Saturday and for the new tour keep on
trucking I'm in Nashville January 25th
Austin January 26th through the 27th get
your tickets at thick birthday 26th so
it'll be important listen you got to get
your fats but you got to get good fats
like Omega sevens like the kind of fats
that Brian Johnson who is that famous
multi-millionaire who wants to live
forever he's 45 years old McAdam is eats
two handfuls every day you know what the
problem with mcus though they they're
only for the rich dude I know until you
go to House of macademia okay what they
affordable macademia they work with 90
plus farmers in South Africa dude all
right it's sustainable and then dude I
love their chocolate covered nuts I love
all you know the 45% macadamia nut bars
I love all that yeah I was having I was
drinking black coffee this morning I
went black coffee why wouldn't you put
Macadamia there that exist uh yeah
they'll give you a gallons worth let me
say it again an American gallons worth
it's pure Macadamia milk if I drink that
macadamia nut milk will I look like the
owner well you're you'll have the best
oils and fats in your body it's great
for satiety meaning you won't be as
hungry great for keeping your weight off
no added sugars oil stabilizers
conservatives like other nut milks turn
into the dime piece like that owner
though that's all I care about that's
not going to happen can I just soak in
that nut milk no that's you're not going
to be as good-looking as the owner of
House of macadamia but if you go to
House of macadamias
docomo milk in the best nuts in the
world all right house of macadamias
a festival for a more beautiful world
our boy Aubrey Marcus is hosting
something where pretty much anything is
possible right it's a great time
November 2nd through the 5th it's at
Area 15 not Area 51 it's Area 15 that is
November second through theth Dude music
Chom I'm a huge fan of Chromo i' go just
for Chromo elderbrook JY Wolf The Glitch
Mob Troy Boy you know why this is great
cuz I'm 56 and I haven't heard of any of
them so you know it you've heard Chromeo
songs well but you know it's going be
very hip if a 56-year-old doesn't know
what the hell it is but I know if Aubrey
Marcus is involved he never misses and
you like burning man this is basically
this is what bur Burning Man used to be
this is The Man Without The Burning y
it's Arcadia and here's your chance to
be part of this legendary freaking
Festival out out yep all you got to do
is go to fitfor service.com Arcadia
right now that's fitfor
service.com k a a you got Chromo Aubrey
Marcus what more could you want it's
Area 15 come on right up my [__] Alle
Yeah man so I I don't know why but I'm
I'm happy for it cuz the yeah that's a
thing about masculinity or whatever the
[__] you want to call it you know it's
like there like people talk about
identifying as a man or a woman you know
just the truth is as a man if you really
honest like if you talk about what it's
like you got to wake up every day and
say today's a good day to die I got all
the answers but [__] right behind
your face most of the time you're like
you know I don't [__] know you know
you're just you're you're making up as
you go along but I think humor is like
the how like you guys do the same it's
like that's how you deal with it like
the world's crazy right now like we woke
up to mass shooting so it's like man
thank God you guys are here you know cuz
like I woke up like I got my kids he SE
he's like Daddy he walked in with a gun
I'm like and he's three yeah and you're
like I don't know here I'm put on Looney
Tunes forget
about it's like it's so heavy so I think
it's an outlet for people you know what
I'm saying that's what we say as well
like a lot of um a lot of time I think
people just come to us as just like a
rest bite from the world you stay away
from politics 100% And just not even
that we stay away from it we just very
just take like a very light-hearted view
on it and we're just very adamant that
we're like we're just two idiots just
talking so
like I shouldn't be allowed to
vote dude I don't know
[__] I'm a [__] and I my vote counts
the same as somebody like that's insan
don't listen to me and I tell you know
cuz Brian's old and Brian's very
educated he's into that stuff I'm not
I've got I've had to get more into it
because we're in California AK North
Korea so I've had to get a little more
into it but I don't you know it's not
it's not the takes on here is it's
nothing nothing you're going to hear
that's original or not regurgitated from
more Brilliant Minds like that's not
what we do but Brian's older and Brian's
very smart and witty with that stuff and
he can do it but it still it doesn't
it's not what the audience Tunes out bro
yeah exactly we start talking about that
stuff we I tune out we'll be talking I'm
like yeah thank God I'll go down that
rabbit hole we start talking about Co
back in the day people like next [__]
off yeah it does get like that as well
and like I think as well like one of the
things that we enjoy is like we like to
just like play Devil's Advocate like we
could have like a conversation about
like really hard-hitting stuff in like
North Korea and stuff and then all of a
sudden we'll be like what if I was Kim
Jong-un though that would be pretty sick
that's that's the move
go down that to be to be a king where
you could be like I'm bored today
someone brushed my teeth yeah exactly
I'm just like I want a baby tiger to
play I tell everyone I don't fart and
I'm just perfect and pure just like
that's kind of cool yeah um so that's
how we take like our stance and
everything like we used to have a moto
just always find the funny in whatever
it is always find the funny um and we do
obviously steer away from like certain
things we so smart from advertisers to
just being authentic it's like you know
like we my boys get around like
yesterday I was at this uh truck shop
job all day long not a single person
talk about Palestine the government
nothing it's just not trucks yeah I I
think humor is like you measure your
life on the amount of times you've
laughed if you think about that sh think
it is though I was thinking about that
it's like you can measure life on your
accomplishments but for the most part
like when you think about your friends
or you think about good things it's like
you are laughing in that memory yeah
exactly man silly goose our entire
relationship is just LOF based on LOF
dude we had you know how your your
iPhone does collage is for
you they said rley sent me one and I was
like did I die I said to him I was like
like he and I going like do 10
years hair I was young and [__] it's
like a montage you play at your
funeral the music as the slow he sent it
to me he was like it just said bro like
as I was [__] got I was crying I was
like oh [__] you play this on my funeral
all right Apple I feel you yeah yeah
you'll look back on that you kids and
then you guys are doing uh live shows
too yeah so we're doing um we just came
off tour a UK tour um doing the live
shows um
and yeah not allowed to talk about we
got got we're going to do some here next
year and then we've got like one in the
UK next year as well and and was the
desire to get on stage when you guys
started now you know what is what it's
not even it wasn't even um we just do
the live shows for fun yeah yeah it's
for it's for them it's not for us yeah
it's for them and that's the thing like
even coming here next year like
realistically speaking we're not even
going to make any money we're just going
to do it um because it's nice to do our
audience is actually majority American I
think was like 40% as American so as in
your audience in general yeah in general
across the world 40% American and we
never spend any time here every time we
do a show everyone's like oh when you
come to America when you come to America
when come to America so we're just going
to come here next year do as much as we
can um but we just do it for fun like
even with this tour um once we sold out
all the dates uh the promoter was like
oh we can just double you want to do
extra shows at all the dates and we're
like nah hell Bor different amount of
work too exctly were you doing theaters
what what yeah so we did theaters um
like between I think for these days
anywhere from like 900 to like 1500 um
yeah Capac you're going to take you're
going to take uh questions from the
audience you're going to just do a pod
so we do um yeah it's more like game
oriented it's very very very very like
different to like um our show um we have
like certain segments that will just
like make very grandiose um and then we
have like a lot of games uh like kind of
like performances and we just [__]
around like yeah just making it like the
most party yeah EX for the fans of
Celebration everything that we do in the
show trying to make that as big and
excessive and obnoxious as possible on
stage first time you went on stage were
you nervous hell it's a different animal
right it's a different like you and him
talking it's just I always forget people
are listen I'll say some wild [__] and
you know things happen but then when
you're out in the crowd you're like oh
[__] yeah oh wow this how you guys
respond at the end of the day sorry bro
at the end of the day we just say stuff
to make each other laugh so when you're
actually in front of like hundreds or
thousands of people you're like damn is
this actually funny or do they actually
think this is cool
thinking here you just you just shooting
exactly you don't do any standups so you
didn't start a stand up we just start
that's the thing as well a lot of people
I think especially like when they meet
us they're expecting like a certain
personality um that they see on the
screen and they forget that like cuz
like a very introverted person and like
I care about making him laugh I don't
really give a [__] about anything else
all everything I do is just to make him
laugh I know what makes him laugh a
secret though yeah exactly and making
yourself laugh I swear to God I think
the minute you start thinking about
what's funny out there you're [__] ex
the idea is like are we laughing if
we're laughing you already know that
when you guys talk and and start talking
about dumb [__] like that there's a huge
audience that wants that stuff cuz
everybody else is just as dumb yeah
exactly and that's what the one thing I
realize that somebody might have a PhD
or somebody might be
be in a job that's really serious that
doesn't mean they don't appreciate the
[__] out of everything you do cuz they
they have a silly side that they can't
express exactly you know or they don't
know it's funny until they hear it
that's yeah yeah yeah that's that's
another thing so Saturday Night Live has
been around for so long because uh
Lauren Michaels philosophy was I'm not
waiting for you to tell me what's funny
I'm going to tell you what's funny and
I'm going to make the audience catch up
to me and the secret of that show was
that he believed that audience was far
more sophisticated than people thought
comedically so he would the idea was to
break ground and get people to go is
that funny it is funny you know that was
what that was that's why they have that
kind of longevity so have you noticed
things changed now you guys are making a
little bit of money if you friends
coming around family yeah people trying
to jump on board um I mean yes or no I
think for me personally it's they show a
lot more love and people like come out
at the Woodworks to be like I had a
message yesterday from someone I went to
primary school with I was like damn I
can't remember your name it's crazy but
um more time it's love than people
trying to like suck blood from you so
it's it's not that bad it's not been too
bad there there's definitely been like
little technical scenarios where I'm
just like bro please you feel
that come on it is what it is guess yeah
yeah if I would I you're getting bigger
it comes with a territory hate how you
guys dealing with the hate it doesn't
not much to hate on with you guys cuz
it's not like you're giving hot takes on
certain situations or other people you
know yeah that's we was trying we always
trying to say as like Evergreen as
possible don't really sides but um there
has been a couple times like we got in
trouble in South Africa the other day
because yeah because basically you were
in South Africa so Bally the South
African audience um on Twitter hated us
for like a week because um God's sake um
so basically they' sent in like someone
had sent in like this Twitter thread and
it was it was from South Africa and half
of it was in English but they were just
pepper in different languages cuz they
speak like 11 different languages over
there they were just pepper in languages
so we were getting frustrated and we
like [__] I want to read it but we can't
read it with all this gibberish I can't
understand it and they were like
gibberish oh God I was
like that's literally it and then it
just he for for gibberish just for
saying yeah and the thing is we use j i
he could say something int intelligent I
like that's gibberish you could say
something um about like magic mind like
dude you're talking gibberish I don't
know that's just how we use it
flippantly um but yeah they weren't
happy at all they angry that's not too
bad though it's not too bad eat a red
dick about that no death threats yet no
that's when you know you've made it yeah
not not I get one on the daily I got
yeah I can imagine
dude I can imagine
bro like a man yeah that thing up like
when you guys did meanest thing people
ever said to you I'm like boy you don't
want me to play that [__] it hurt your
feelings that's yeah I take that stuff
seriously I hate that's one thing I I
take it to heart when people can yeah
I'm super sensitive about it I could see
like 10,000 positive comments and
someone could literally comment like and
I'm like dude what the [__] we're wired
that way exactly your brain's wired that
way we just don't ever Rec comments now
but they did a study on like like people
that go out and just hate on [__] and
you'd think it'd be like some dude in
his basement you know a lot of times it
can be but what was fascinating about
the study was that it's a
cross-pollination of people you would
never respect kindergarten teachers
lawyers and there's a there's something
about some people who are just like
nobody can see behind the keyboard
that's the majority though that's what
this study said you You' said that you
referenced that study for the past 10
years and I've never seen it it wasn't
10 years but we no you've been telling
us about that and we went through this
was a recent thing I don't know if
lawyers are getting on there being
like they are I don't think so study
listeners what lawyer was going to give
that up like that's
me to be fair I was hating on that ones
that get hate you know obviously when a
lot of people that get hate on their
outfit or on whatever they you can do
anything and there are people that just
want to like that and it's a way of
getting their [__] out yeah people do
get a serious kick out of commenting and
the thing is as well like you can't take
it seriously cuz really like I don't
know anyone in my life who would opt in
and comment in something so to take the
words of someone that I can't even
conceptualize as a human being oh I
don't take Yelp reviews serious know
anybody leaves a Yelp review or like a
food review like my girl like how many
stars is I'm like who gives a [__] you
think of people raing I feel like you
leave reviews do you you leave reviews
you'll leave a bad review like even if I
have a badb I don't say [__] now now
these these this she is your manager
manager very successful handsome good
friend is that's a handsome handsome man
yeah this is fight Tyson Fury next week
Jesus Christ looks looks athletic he's a
very famous musician is that true move
on
Sor he outfit L though man I wish I I
knew you like that outfit I celebrate
that I would get traded for cigarettes
if I wore that oh wow you know what I'm
saying but he pulls that [__] off I I
don't have that kind of Sy cigarettes
little bottom boy that's yeah that's our
ter now bottom boy you're a bottom boy
bot boy a bottom boy do you guys keep up
with uh CU I mean he's the biggest most
famous boxer on the planet but Tyson
Fury out there he's a Manchester kid
yeah yeah he fights Francis Satur
Saturday yeah what are we Thursday oh
yeah Saturday you're from London though
right London yeah okay I thought not but
he lives in Manchester right yeah lives
in Manchester yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I I think it's unbelievable man
what's interesting out there where you
guys are across the pond is like MMA is
bigger out there that in boxing's bigger
out there like it there's more they
celebrate it more they do better
coverage than our than our coverage here
yeah so it's like the start like Tom
Aspen who's fighting for the
championship he's from Manchester pretty
close but it's like UK like Combat
Sports is M it's just getting massive
man KSI with the cross pollination
there's a big fight mentality in England
come from a violent culture let's be
honest big big fight mentality and like
everything is like uh we don't I've
noticed this so I I was talking to
someone about this the other day and
like in England I don't remember the
last time I saw a fight but everything
especially across like dudes is like
physical violence is the first point of
court so like you can watch a lot
we watch a lot of like American podcast
and American shows and like YouTube
channels and stuff like that where
there's a lot of like got your culture
like people invite people on
intentionally like to like [__] them
over um whereas like in England I don't
really see that they will [__] you over
once it's said and done and then they'll
hit Twitter but like there's not a
scenario where someone can invite me on
a show to like try and out me in front
of cuz I will fight you yeah I will
fight like but you know why because you
guys don't have the same gun issues that
we have exactly in America like some d
cut me off the other day and I even I
was like it's all good man and he he was
like he wanted to fight in my head if I
was in England I'm like let's do it yeah
it should go my way let's see how it
goes you it should go my way go my way
we'll see how it goes my man it will go
you better have a sword but in and even
then but in America it's like might
probably has a gun I don't want sh in
England I be like yeah let's do it
chance having a gun whatever might have
a knife but guns here are everywhere so
you guys are to do that cuz you don't
have the same have F cuffs yeah here now
you can get shot in the face yeah you
you have of knif crime though you get
knifed up pretty quick oh yeah that's
the last resort or the only Resort yeah
yeah yeah yeah it doesn't I guess it
does happen it happened a lot when we
were younger though that's when it was
like
like a
shank shot you don't recover from that
you know you just but I was in Bogner
reges bner reges I know I was shooting a
show for Discovery Channel it's [__]
Jes whatever I I thought he was going to
say I was doing stand up I was
like
CHR
reg I went the guy they told me not to
go out cuz uh it was dangerous I go I'm
from [__] New York shut up I go out
and I'm just at a bar I just want to see
what's up and when I tell you I I don't
know how many fights I saw I I couldn't
believe it for no reason it just kept
happening unbelievable and they they
said that's where you can get stabbed
you know that yeah those are like there
C yeah like certain like really really
like poverty line areas that's just it
just boredom it's culture yeah yeah yeah
cuz there's like um the benefit system
in England is like some of the best in
the world so like the yeah yeah exactly
so people can just live off benefits
never have to look for a job and
everyone's just bored bored everyone's
just bored so literally all there is to
do is just get drunk and F yeah just
like drunk kids yeah just drunk white
people with bad teeth for real just just
aggressive [__] yeah yeah just like
you'll find that you want to go to
England yeah you'll find that not the
most attractive group right and I've
seen better it's not Miami yeah well we
got some ugly people here too yeah but
you go down south you're going see some
I bet yeah yeah it's um it's tough I
mean everywh has ugly people this is
pretty though la is nice shouting lot
homeless shouting lot hom sh where you
guys are at where you guys are at is
like the American Idol for homeless
that's the most talented homeless in the
world got to go down to Venice and
places like down to M lot of homeless in
Venice too but not anymore not as much
anymore they got to handle you'll see
enough but where you guys are at in weho
is the I mean that's the capital I mean
you could go to Skid Row where it gets
super dicey but where you're at you're
going to see a ton of hom them [__]
are talented oh bro just shouting dude
we were wed we walked to like CVS
yesterday like 10-minute walk I see like
three dudes just screaming at the top of
the lungs hell I was like damn dude just
for no reason yeah where's the manners
yeah at least Hess in England they have
the good manners to sh ask for money
yeah they're just there quiet please
please you go down Hollywood Boulevard
them [__] juggling chainsaw just
trying to get a dollar man chainsaw wild
pants off and [__] yeah it's cool that's
capitalism man yeah dude welcome to
America each his own it's called The
Marketplace hustling yeah I would I
would get closer to the beach man yeah
yeah hit hit Venice you'd like it that
all right fair play man here when AB
Kenny AB Kenny how long you here for uh
we leave on we fly to New York on Sunday
so we got a couple more what's in New
York same more of the same what which
what other shows have you done out here
uh we did a couple yesterday so we did a
movie one uh which is called rers of the
Lost podcast Raiders of the Lost podcast
movie Geniuses they yeah have their
black Bel guys movie guys love movies
series anime I like a couple of yours
not
loads and by a couple of mine he means
the parts I played the small parts I
played that I had nothing to like J
showed up Joker was excellent yeah don't
blank you [__] you can see me in the
[__] mirror when I was when I was
shooting that [__] I brought the
director over I've known him forever I
go tdd come here he goes what's up he I
go I'm not going to be in this movie I'm
spending five [__] days room called
you up yeah he called Mak this movie bro
but Brian's out there for like three or
four weeks and I had to do something uh
I'm in a wig no no I was doing some show
I was doing I I was doing sub out in New
York and Brian goes dude we just uh we
just wrapped for the day come meet me at
a bar I was like all right and I just
got off um I forget what I was doing
with that Andy that Big Show for Bravo I
was doing something and so I'm like dude
yeah I get off I'll meet you at this bar
you didn't warn me I go to meet him at
the bar and he's with the
the but he didn't give me a heads up and
Lee so I walked in I'm like the [__]
and so I sit down and but he didn't say
I told Lee that so Lee Lee hates when
people so Lee's really small you know
who he is yeah and he's great and Lee
doesn't he's in Game of Thrones too
right no
no no I know he's not the small person
Game of Thrones no no no he was in that
too no I know no I know I no he's not
the no dude I know he's not the main
actor in Game of Thrones they don't you
got understand Le's a kind of guy
walking down the street when you walk
down the street with him cars will stop
to let him go he can't stand that like
[__] he also dates girls he's he
killed it I don't know he goes on dates
with these with regular siiz girls so
[__] great Jesus that's not supposed
to be a compliment I'm saying he goes on
dates with like women with like two eyes
man I'm saying he's very aware of the
effect he has and people always try to
like accommodate him which drives him
nuts so I said to him as we're there I
go I know that's not him leil Le yeah
he's in the Joker and I go great actor
and I [__] little
person it's not we man you [__] it's
it's not Le sorry sorry Le he's going to
kill me it's uh just go go to the
J go to go to Joker small guy he's the
best so I tell him I say listen
Brennan's coming and he's not going to
I'm not going to tell him typ in small
guy yeah okay there's Brian right away
nice yeah yeah there he is there he
is spelling yeah he's the man so he's
got a great sense of humor too and I go
I go four foots being General yeah yeah
very small I I said to him I go I said
to Le I go uh I'm not telling Brennan
anything I just want to see how he
reacts and he's going to act like oh hey
how you do
this bar is Buzz and I you're notle
what's up I like no you know what you
did you went like this
oh what do you mean oh and but you like
you're all right I'm like I'm good man
and then we were just I was like trying
not to laugh it's [__] you could have
gave me a heads up man we got to kick
out of see hey why you trying to act
normal yeah he's the man he's the manent
man that's very cool he went on a on a
movie podcast movie podcast story flat
by the way don't think we don't notice I
killed him afterwards yeah carry on all
right we went on a um rship C called
lovers and friends that's the only two
we've done so far we've got this and
we've got um another one after this
called retirement house and then we've
got Kev on stage Kev stage and we've got
Kev stage great who else we got don't
trip don't trip oh yeah we were supposed
to see uh [__] so many your your boy
which one Rick Glassman oh Rick's the
man yeah but I don't I don't think it's
been booked in but we'll see have you
have you done any pods yet where it's
awkward where you don't Vibe with the
other host um you guys seem pretty
before in in in the UK we've done loads
in the UK that some um that's been
awkward yeah not for the whole time but
there's definitely somewh people think
that like we we will carry the
conversation and then like the work if
we were yeah if we were a guest like we
come in to chill yeah I'm not carrying
the load here this is I do have to do it
every week this is like a day off um so
yeah there's definitely been a some
where they're just
like even to be fair even um on Raiders
for a little there was a few bits they
expected the conversation but we've
never met before so like there's they'll
bring up a topic that isn't mov related
and then we're just like mhm yeah it's
not it's not movie related yeah yeah
yeah yeah so they're just trying to have
like normal chitchat you guys do you
guys think there movie Buffs do you
think movies are in the past 10 years
have gotten better worse are the movies
you like 10 years worse are they are
right that's how I feel so the movies
you you reference are usually 10 years
ago yeah there's a couple there's been
don't on this there's been a couple
bangers but like like what all in the
last 10 years yeah what do you think um
to be fair Joker Joker was decent I
really like the Joker yeah Joker sick
second one's going to be sick as well
yeah agree um what's the last Tim
Dylan's in the second one is he really
yep does he have a bigger part than you
I assume is he go U Tim Yeah Tim Todd
loves comedy so he's hilarious not
surprising yeah as far as like doing
just the P like some well you guys do it
together but I do a podcast where you're
just talking to the camera as far as
someone doing it just to camera Tim's
the best the world has I've listened to
a few of his and he for like an hour
straight he doesn't take a breath the
memory recall is like I so jealous of
stuff like that it pisses me off cuz I'm
so slow dude I got CT yeah yeah it's I
mean you do that [__] yeah it's it's
unbelievable man but um you guys you
guys are killing it though um I have to
give you guys uh your flowers you guys
are probably a massive inspiration for
for our podcast I think oh appreciate
yeah man I um I struggle I was saying to
F the other day I struggle with a lot of
poster syndrome um sometimes when people
will send us in messages like oh bro
like you really really really help me um
like these drives to work and these
commutes to work like it's just the
worst thing in the entire world and I
hate it but the only thing is I know
every Monday it's going to be a good
drive to work I know that for a fact and
that's something I can roll on every
week uh and I feel like an imposter
because the only time I've ever felt
that is when I was doing the commute to
work and I would listen to this podcast
come on real yeah yeah yeah so big that
impostor syndrome a little emotional
that impost me too that impostor
syndrome never goes away if it does then
you're you're a prick soad it never goes
away I it never it never leaves it never
that's why consistency sorry to
interrupt but that's why consistency so
important man because I'm the same I
have certain podcasts I listen to and if
it's not there when I'm hoping I'm like
mother [__] you get so down cuz it's
like such a it's a routine thing and
you're banking on these guys getting it
done man you know somebody said uh I
think it was Gary Shandling I don't know
if you remember him but he's a great
comic in this yeah one of the greatest
one of the greatest and he uh and he
said it was I came remember with the
comedian and the comedian was [__] who
was the comedian really well-known
comedian very funny and I think it might
have even been Eddie Murphy or someone
they said I never feel comfortable at a
Hollywood party and Gary shanling said
if you feel comfortable at a Hollywood
party you are Billy Crystal and that
also means you're not funny anymore oh
and I and I to your point I'm so glad
you said that I I think you should
always feel like an impostor and I think
you should always feel like a little bit
uncomfortable maybe we're comedy any
anytime I do like if I walk into any if
I'm doing a big podcast or um any venue
I go to for standup I feel like when I
walk in the Green Room they're like what
are you doing yeah exactly like I'm oh
I'm the here for the show like no you're
not yeah okay no doubt like no argument
either okay no yeah I'll just no yeah I
flew all the way from no I got it you're
also just bigger than everybody else in
ex athlete and just with these Misfit
Comics No it's not that has nothing do
with my you're saying you're physically
when you broke into the the world it all
you always kind of we kind of pushed you
into it like when we were doing podcast
we would do live shows be like 1,200
people and I would go I I would look at
him and go you're going out first I'm
going to be late and he'd be like what I
go yeah you're going to go out and tell
a story for 10 minutes I could never do
that to him he would he just wouldn't
go 1200 people
never I promise everything I love
everything I love I wouldn't go but even
even when I was in UFC Football it has
nothing to do with my size even even
when I was on the football team uh in
the UFC I always felt the same that
doesn't go away so you should I think as
well though there's also like the flip
side of it I listened to an interview
with uh what's his name sadguru oh yeah
um and he said his take on imposter
syndrome to an extent which I believe
especially in like business and stuff he
said you should only feel like an
impostor if you believe that if all of
it was taken away from you you wouldn't
be able to get it back so if you was to
start from scratch
think you're and think all the fame and
the Su and knew who you were
you if you truly believe that you would
never get back here then you should feel
like an imposter if you know for a fact
that you you know enough and you learn
enough and you're intelligent enough
charismatic enough whatever you need to
do to get back you're still going to
make it you should you belong here and
you should feel like you belong that's a
great heart dat yeah that's that's so
[__] true it's I I think I think
longevity too like staying relevant as a
[__] it's difficult man and like
it's another thing thing as well is like
um I always knew that I told him from
the start I always knew that our podcast
was going to be successful because I'm
my worst critic ever like I hate
everything that I do I don't want to
hear my voice I don't want to see my
face I hate everything so when we did
our first episode and I listened to it
and I laughed I was like okay cool it's
going how do you keep if I can like it
how do you keep yourself true to that do
you watch the the podcast have you done
I do now because
um we only because we take um all the
clips that we uh put out go through us
first and we review all of it like we
don't edit it anymore but um everything
still goes through us so we have to
watch it um and I still don't like
watching it it's it's the worst um but
it's just a necessary evil um but yeah I
think I knew from the job I think a lot
of people even like we said when
everyone has a
podcast I will only start something if I
know I'm going to be good at it I'm not
going to embarrass myself like that like
public shame is like my worst fit so I
would never start if I didn't know and I
think a lot of people just think like oh
this is cool this is fun like I enjoy
standup very very very much I would
never do it cuz I know I'm not I
wouldn't be good at it how do you know
that's not true I just don't have that t
disagree with you we're not comedians
I've seen you guys yeah but we make each
other laugh I don't care I've seen you
guys I don't think I'll be good well but
you have an imagination but you know
what B the other thing with them I don't
think you need to do it
oh take take it from a guy who's done
sometimes you're going to spread
yourself so thin stand up is the hardest
thing you ever do so that takes so much
energy it's going to you can only do so
much oh for sure yeah that's another
thing we you do this three times a week
so we do it so we have a second YouTube
channel that we do so at the minute
we're recording twice a week we record
our main show twice twice a week we do
our reacts um Channel once a week and
then we've we're about to launch a
patreon only show you only have time for
this once a week yeah we focus on all
energy on this and this is working which
yeah which benefits us massively because
we don't rely on brand deals they're
nice and stuff but we don't rely on
anything else we just do everything like
in house
you and you get sponsors and all that
yeah yeah we have Lo sponsors um but
yeah mainly we make more from the show
than we do from like our sponsors and
Our Brands and stuff that we do outside
this is our main focus beautiful
beautiful don't don't [__] with it yeah
never we can't
never can't go back imagine going back
quicking a 9 to5 now back we had a
conversation yesterday we walking we're
walking back from the shop yesterday and
I was like man life is so sick dude like
can you imagine we we actually live this
life and he was like James I promise you
I can't go back whatever we need to do
we need to do whatever a
jail I'm
never if I got start only fans and keep
this life whatever it takes I've got
pretty toes dude I'll do what it takes
yeah I'll do some funky [__] keep this
life going man for my kids 100% yeah be
careful keep your nut small cuz if you
get a really big nut all of a sudden
you've got to do it so yeah yeah yeah
exactly man I need to borrow money
money huh what happened was that P on
Magic mine again oh yeah guys magic mine
is a hell of a I think I can feel the
cooking to be fair it's [__] I'm
telling you yeah bro so we started it
because he he took one and he was
talking to me like this and I was like
man you're kind of aggressive he goes
yeah and I go you took that magic M he
goes [__] A I it
feels so he was like yeah get some
problem if you I feel like if you drink
coffee and then you take a magic mine it
makes it's something about it that do
you feel it or no hon yeah I feel good
Focus like I'm having intrusive thought
yeah right I keep looking at you
thinking pretty sure I could pick you
up
PA strong just pretty sure I could Prett
sure I could how strong are you I'm
pretty strong bro can you imag from this
fun life to going back to [__] being
a personal trainer you so you were a
personal trainer personal trainer I was
man that explains that explains your
chest thank you dude and your ass dude
personal TR thank you by the way you're
like you don't think I you don't think I
I I a man in because I I you drank me in
I mean drank you in in a he also
describes Fighters is banged out Jesus I
I makes me feel sick listen I take I
drink you in in a semi straight way is
what I'm trying to say right yeah but
when I I I'll look at a man's ass and
legs to see if he's an athlete if he's
hitting that part first
and I notic you got a bit of a tail
piece bro I used to have a problem man I
us to stop squatting because my takes
all of it my cords weren't growing for
years and I was all ass bro so I had to
start doing like hack squats and like
got that Nicki Minaj
body hungry too this magic M makes us
horny [__] put a filter on them lenses
I'll give you something to
drink talking about talking about some
brown on white
crime no bro I said it I said it out
Brown on why cry Jes this this brought
to you by Magic M magic give me some
stock [__] like uh we can't do
this yeah but so were you an athlete
before this no so I um we've always been
big into sports like nothing but I I was
a boxer when I was young played a lot of
basketball and then I stopped growing so
I stopped playing basketball never got
into what we call soccer you call
football um I personally I [__] hate
the cold I hate the cold dude so I never
I never played football as kid I played
with my friends but makes me a coward I
hate so I was um he doesn't he doesn't
deal I'm I'm such a [__] I got a long
neck I can't conserve heat you also have
no body fat so it's you yeah I'm
shredded as a
[__] see me later I'm taking my
shirt off I'm going to treat you I'm
going to treat you you guys will drink
me in too thank you sir yeah thank you
sir but yeah boxing and basketball I
want to pick you fingers bro I'm sorry
it's just
theck you you just have that body where
it's like I could kill him no bro I got
a [__] wrestler you guys going to
leave him like man that's F that guy's
gay though right yeah for sure man
hopefully do a little boxing and
wrestling too oh yeah I heard that you
yeah yeah I'll keep you busy definitely
[__] you up I
saw keep you busy I keep you
busy I got I got some tricks you know
what I mean old Li with some tricks I'm
a three star white belt so well nice
have you guys ever got into it like on
the show but you don't your personal
don't seem like it we ever like me and
him have straight up
arguments we've never had an in our
entire in our entire friendship we only
had one argument ever oh no I got anger
issues I've gotten in his face now he
pull my head off serly I have anger he
has horrible anger issues again the the
dynamic is different as well cuz you
know he would just like he's older but
we we could we don't we can't take that
risk cuz it would be like he's Nigerian
he's got a whole clan behind him your
generation keep saying clan for some
reason because Nigerian he's got if
you're Nigerian and you marry a Nigerian
you're marrying their whole family am I
wrong and also if you [__] with him
you're going to have to [__] with his
brothers his cousins they'll come from
logos you're you're it's a disaster your
your children will have to contend with
be tough bro but yeah we we've never
never aru no issues never ever ever um
no we we we we actually I'm kidding we
get along like we get
along come on here and you find out we
hate each other we've never we've never
we've gotten into it on text and then
I'll call oh but he'll call cuz once we
talk it's like it's over yeah we usually
do like um if every time we have an
issue we do like a little love sandwich
I was start off like bro I love you but
but good for you issue and then be like
anyway but anyway do what you want to do
but I love you this is my problem well
it's a marriage kid don't kid yourself
you guys have a business and a huge
thing going that's a marriage and you're
as strong as your union and so you have
to learn how and I I was thinking about
that with us a long back in the day is
like we had to figure [__] out right now
there's no left or right turn like it's
like we got to be honest with each other
if something's bugging you you got to be
honest about it and it's the same thing
it's some heavy [__] too like when we
got when I got fired from Fox I call him
I was like hey we don't have the studio
anymore he's like I'm like I got
fired but don't worry I I and I already
did I was like I already have a studio
lined up we'll figure it out then I made
shirts like bet against us and all this
[__] the best the best is I can tell
when some shit's going down in his life
cuz I'll get this text what's up just
randomly what the [__] is this
fishing just how you doing I'm like hey
he goes hey what's going on I go not
much anyway we'll just he'll start
talking I'm just waiting as he's well
I'll open up with something I don't give
a [__] I'm like how's your uh Jiu-Jitsu
going yeah I'm like huh huh and then man
and then it'll start yeah yeah what
would you do I would just get a text
with my name and capital letters yeah
James I how you know some [__] up with
ACH of
a that's how you know some [__] up yeah
facts wow yeah yeah that's that's life
man it never stops there's always a fire
to put out always a
problem you right no matter how good I
work up to like 37 messages this morning
cuz there a time difference waking up
here everyone's like basically finished
their day at home 35 messages all about
35 problems I was like bro bro heavy
lies the ground exactly yeah I I was I
was thinking about the other day I woke
up and I was just stressing about some
[__] then that's kind of what's good
about the Israeli conflict where you're
like well my house has no murder my
house is a murder free zone let start
with that and I'm not in physical pain
so you have you guys don't have kids do
you no yeah shit'll change and and then
I think for for you guys I think for you
guys too and I'm sure it's coming is
eventually you get to a certain level
you guys are there where one of the
executives with the TV networks I'm like
this would work on TV we've seen like
with uh Deuces Deuces Mero it's what we
do is not for TV it never trans stay
independent man it never works stay
radical and independent for real when
you sell out then the fan base like oh
we're out man and try coming back and
like no we're good dude yeah we were
talking about uh a few months ago we
were talking about uh KSI and KSI like
still does even though all the other
stuff he's still got going on he still
does like really corny like Try Not to
Laugh YouTube videos every week and
that's what made him big right I didn't
realize how big KSI was uh but I guess
out here you know cuz especially I'm
older but maybe the young kids do but
out I didn't realize how massive he was
cuz you know he's the reason why Prime's
as big it's not everyone thinks it's
Logan it's KSI is the reason why so big
cuz he could have done it with Jay so he
still
huge bigger than ever he just fought
yeah he just fought we went to his fight
last made was was not good in person not
good no it was equally as bad in person
as it looked on the screen it was not a
boxer he's really not but you know what
the pro that the problem is is I don't
know what expectations you you guys had
going in I don't have high expectations
for it so hard so if so if they fight at
a level that's out of 10 it's a two I
thought it was going to be a one so two
I'm like all good so hard but but it's
not even about that like if you're if
you're thinking you're going to see a
Tyson Fury type of fight you don't know
what the [__] you're talking about so
for those guys I give them their flowers
I take a lot of [__] from my people you
know who are fight experts but it's also
like that's you got to remember like
what Tommy Fury's doing right you got to
remember Tommy Fury in England he's big
out here he's big right but
Tommy the the name is prize fighting
prize is the main thing Tommy Fury is a
prize fighter he's made more money in
three fights than at the Cruiserweight
division the champion he's made more
than that guy will make ever in his
entire career fights and so people are
hating on like but the remember it's
prize fighting he's made $30 million I
think in three fights Jesus I didn't
even know that D he's like 20 to 30 we
don't know the exact es probably 20 to
30 million and he thought you YouTubers
he's one you f
he's code it's also not easy it's also
not easy to get in there you're still
getting hit in the face I mean you're
still train I me there's no risk to him
either cuz he he he's fighting KSI the
KSI is not going to knock him out
exactly Jake's not you probably not
going to knock him out so it's like he
beat the game bro he's won what would
you do with that kind of money you ever
think about that how different would
your life be honestly I would have
picked you
up wor about the the
impulsive as as you when you lift from
the legs you'll be fine would you would
you guys ever get into the uh that kind
of that YouTube boxing you guys are big
enough numbero I'm waiting for the call
and I promise you I've said before cuz I
know I would be the guy who gets dropped
my ass would hit the C twice and I'll do
that double bounce look up and be like
[__] yeah the world is watching I
wouldn't I wouldn't be able to live down
the
embarrassment I have way too much pride
there's a lot riding on that sh it's not
happening man he got offered he got
recently offered
I bet I saw I saw the numbers they were
floating around and I was like come here
I need to talk to you it's not Tommy
Fury what's up MMA or booking here's the
thing if it was like uh influencer
boxing you sign me up I'll make I'll do
that real that would be a piss You' do
three fights a night yeah i' be easy
payday like hey kids sit front row but
the problem is is I got offered a beer
knuckle MMA fight
Jesus with a with a big another big
monster n not worth it no hell no
I was like we could start training now
I'll hold Ms Brian was like it'd be good
for Content I'm like bro if this is what
we have to do we're done a little
leech sh wet my beak a little bit let me
get my 20 25% I'm but you guys would
even consider it wouldn't consider it
you know it's coming I bet it will come
but the more and the thing is the more I
say I'll never do it the more likely I
am to get the email but I don't I'm not
doing it yeah but you you you don't have
to you stick to this [__] be funny
that's what we need you don't need to
get on I feel like a lot of times you're
now you're lending yourself to the
spectacle of things and that's a debate
right so now now it's just like I don't
know so you don't want to compromise who
you are for attention I don't see the
point man it's just like it's just like
the money is not going to make is and
literally unless it is like 30 million
and I'm like oh okay cool like life yeah
it's life changing it doesn't stoping I
could just show up and then just take
like a punch and be like oh no I'm done
and it doesn't I didn't give a [__] it
doesn't matter I'm done with you guys
like it's over but like for the money
cuz like um swarms UK musician who
always fights on the the misfit cards
and every every fight he's lower and
lower and lower on the card he gets
rocked every single time he won one and
he's a rapper as well his his his vade
is gone like he's just now he's just
known as just the joke that gets knocked
out in 10 seconds um he actually got
knocked out in like 11 seconds the other
day on that same
card embarrassing and they're not even
paying him enough for him to stop cuz he
keeps coming he keeps coming back he
might not be doing well in his other
lane so that's why not now as well yeah
music's done so yeah I I I could never
be another hard to look good when you're
but but but I think guys like KSI Logan
Paul Jake like they can lose in their
fan base they don't care change cuz the
what's different about them than real
fighting is that they don't care about
wins and loss they care about the
buildup and they care about the
characters everything's a win it's a
reality show even like literally the KSI
losing to Tommy straight after Jake just
LOF a Tommy now KSI Jake is going to be
bigger than I ever would have been
before it doesn't matter which what
happens they just know how to manipulate
to make it I'm sorry to be ignorant
about this I don't follow this is KSI
and going to fight Jake now they've been
talking about for a while build they
have be they've had like beef over years
beef over years I think he's got his
hands full with Jake Jak oh Jake will
[__] him up yeah Jak would [__] him up
KSI knows but my thing what KSI just got
big just from like video games so he was
like a FIFA YouTuber same with all the
siden um but he's just like the biggest
out of his group so the siden do you
know you guys know about the soid is
just like a YouTuber it's like the
biggest YouTube group if you will in the
world probably it's just like a bunch of
guys who used to sit in their room and
play FIFA they all got together yeah and
then they just they were just all
friends and they used to just like cross
pollinate and they formed this group
called The Sid men and KSI was one of
them and he's just propelled himself to
be just on Timberlake of that group
exactly exactly that's exactly so they
they they were a podcast or what were
they no so they were just Gamers dude oh
gamers
get
younger I'm sorry let me take out my
dentes so they all have their own they
all have their own separate YouTube
channels and they would just like
collaborate and then stream and just
play games and then like they formed
like a quote unquote group called The
Sidman um and then they have videos
together on their simman Channel and
they all have their separate separate
YouTube channels as well they make crazy
money they all have like every all the
individuals have like millions and
millions of subs and they just
celebrated their 10 year anniversary
last month last week week had a cool
post he was like this is why do I went
from this to this like he got in great
shape and obviously has Fame and money
now he showed a picture of him in the
boxing ring you know he's kind of jacked
and shape and they showed when he first
started on YouTube he's just like this
nerdy kid on there with glasses talk
about the glow up about me if that
forehead stays there dude I was going to
say as as long as the bandana stays on
the Glow's crazy yeah there he is yeah
man money can't fix the forehead but he
crushing it headline is are you saying
he wears a bandana cuz oh bro if you're
not seen it without it it's concerning
yeah concerning is concerning disaster
yeah it's dister dister you say in
French um speak French doesn't matter
you guys knew that uh that's crazy yeah
to go from that to like this I mean I
got to get on top five most famous
people massive czy and I knew Prime was
big when my son's in baseball and it's
like my turn turn the dads have to bring
the snacks every game whatever and it's
my turn to bring the snacks and I
brought Gatorade like a goddamn
gentleman and these kids were like
where's the prime godamn gent yeah I was
like what prime Fu with your Gatorade
1990s they were going to Riot they were
Furious there's no Prime and right there
I'm like oh whoa that was before it was
like I know it my 12-year-old is like
cuz I get it for free I don't know where
the [__] it comes from did you set that
up I get okay so I get a free shipment
literally grabs it and just goes home
with it every yeah they send it to us as
well and my barber came around to cut my
hair he took all of it he was like I was
like oh do you want some prime he was
like yes please please please please for
my kids and I was like all right cool
how many do you want he's like I have I
have seven kids I was like I just gave
him two crates I like just go and
they've even like they've even got like
they're making it four kids cuz they've
got the new like glow Berry flavor and
they've got like rare ultra rare like
the different bottles they Trea them
like Pokémon cards yeah oh [__] it's
insane crushing it Crush great marketing
man they know what they're doing they
really know what they're doing they'll
sell that for oh the yeah that the
amount of M like Logan told me the
amount of money his first check they he
got from the I was like wait what D he's
got some cash that's cool it nuts nuts
like you're done you know you'd be done
are you guys going to do flagrant or
anything in New York no basement yard oh
they'd be great with
schy do you know schy you he we just
missing we were supposed to go to he did
a show in
London the day before we flew I think
and we were supposed to go but our
recording session ran late but he's back
now when you're in New York I'll connect
you guys when we leave yeah sure we
happy do it man yeah I'm a big fan of
his man he's funny that's a good podcast
yeah for sure I like fragrant yeah yeah
one of my faves first time in New York
or you've been in New York it would be
our first time really yeah I went when I
was like seven years
old it's going to be sick that's wild be
you're going to like that man especially
down where Schultz's uh studio is that's
a cool area okay yeah you can't you'll
just you'll be like all the boys up
there like does Steph know he do you
know Chrissy um I've never met him but
yeah I know who he is great he be a good
one for you guys you are garbage or we
are garbage or whatever is that are you
garbage they're great yeah with Kevin
yeah yeah sick man I'm down for man yeah
we'll make it happen after this
yeah we got another two hours I hope you
guys are fine with this bro I'm having
I'm having a great time man you got some
current events chin yeah I do but quick
question for fuad and James as well just
as a producer you guys do the reaction
videos do you guys get demonetized for
playing other videos at the beginning um
but we started to manipulate how we what
we react to so we don't get demonetized
anymore I think the first two yeah so
what you need to do is you need to
exclusively react to Tik toks yeah Tik
Tok yeah yeah and also try and make sure
they're original Tik toks because a lot
of Tik toks are just repurposed YouTube
content that's a good point so make sure
it's not repurposed YouTube content I'm
not going to lie our editor goes through
hell every week he uploads an episode I
think at least two clips get cut for
copyright um but so far I think aart
from one every video on our reacts
channel is monetized that's great yeah
man it's doing really really well that's
a good note Jin also James when did you
get your neck tattoo cuz I'm curious if
you were oh let me see James you have
one to it
or I'm a big anime fan so I have a this
is from Naruto it's ausy Cloud um I got
this I remember when we were still
working I said as soon as I quit my job
I'm going to get t on my neck so no one
will that's when you know there's no
going back no one will ever give
whenever I see a guy with a neck T I'm
like
okay
B move another I'm BS deep in anime kind
of a muscular nerd in a good way exactly
man I want to get one on my neck for for
my kiddos but uh it's always dicey you
just I've I've always wanted neck always
you should do always wanted neck yeah I
sold this TV show and then I think about
him like if I'm on TV with the neck you
know oh bro those times are over man get
out of your head yeah you might be right
yeah for sure man I loads of people have
t was on their neck it's never ever ever
ever issue for me it'd be 56 just get a
a unicorn like it's nice distraction
from the
um maybe if James serious dude if you
you you're look like David Dukes like
people just assume you're in the KKK at
your age with it if I really yeah you
can't dude damn you can't like I mean if
it was a swaser maybe just anything even
if it was like get shits and digs right
here yeah do it bro get just get my face
there yeah and just bottom boy and
and Bot bottom boy bot boy bottom boy a
Fu G what do you got J it's only gay if
you're smiling all
right this isn't a pouch this is a pouch
what's up guys if you're like me I used
to use white nicotine pouches all the
time non-stop whatever it was if you saw
me on podcast your boy had it in if you
saw me on stage I had it in if I'm at
the gym I had nicotine in my mouth at
all times and then I found black Buffalo
they make the same great flavors that
you know we're talking about mint winter
green they got my favorite the straight
and they're all tobacc free that means
no tobacco stem or Leaf is in these and
they're made in the US of a US OFA
product so you know it's good it's black
Buffalo so if you're 21 or older and you
use nicotine or tobacco head on over to
Black Buffalo that's black buffalo.com
you kind of already touched on this but
um if you want to go even deeper into
this whole thing where Jon Jones got
injured he supposed to fight Ste oh he t
pack or something right yeah dude to P
off the bone what then Dana goes all
right we got a new fight for the intern
belt of Tom Asen fellow uh Englishman
Tom asol who's a Savage versus Sergey
pavlovich and that'd be for the intern
belt but it makes no sense cuz John's
out probably a year and then I don't
know if it's common knowledge but JN and
Stipe who were originally supposed to
fight in two weeks and M Garden both
them are going to retire the the plan
was for both of them to retire after
this fight it's like a legendary fight
but now it's it's I I feel like UFC
dropped the ball a little bit like just
make the new fight for the actual vacant
belt yeah yeah yeah for sure how the
[__] did he do you think he's going to
come back in a year or do you think he's
just going to sack it off uh yeah I
don't know cuz's he's not young
38 36 I think I think he's 36 yeah I
think he's 36 but but that's a but
that's a lot of miles on a 36y old he's
been doing for a he hasn't taken a lot
of damage besides the custen fight and
stuff H he's taking some damage yeah
yeah yeah yeah man is he um Aspen is a
minus 130 favorite if you gave aspal a
12we camp I I would have him as a minus
300 your your boy Tom aspal should be
the heavyweight champion of the world I
think he's the most talented dude he's
so [__] you you think he would give
John Fitz he's the only guy you can give
John Fitz yep wow oh nice yeah yeah he's
a Savage I really close with Fury too
they train together yeah yeah that
doesn't surprise me they do train
together yep they've trained together
yeah they came up together yeah [__] do
we think um you would know after this
after Francis fights on Saturday do you
think Dan's going to give him a shout
trying to sort something out or do you
think it's the the boat s oh man I think
uh Furia beat Francis and then I then
Fury's going to fight usk right they
announc that did you see it no I didn't
see it but promoting his second fight
before he even had this fight it so they
announced Francis Tyson and then they
announced Tyson and usyk it was so
disrespectful but Tyson on Ariel was
saying he's like cuz arel was like D I
feel like that was bad taste like doing
that and Tyson goes I agree with you
100% that was out of my control he's
like I had nothing to do it he goes
notice I didn't announce it he's like
those sa is where it's at he's like they
announced it he's like and I have no say
in it he's like I don't like that that
makes it look like I'm overlooking
Francis which is not the case he's like
so I agree bad taste I'd say Francis
looks fairly good in this fight which is
a tall order I think Dan will come and
knocking but if Francis gets knocked out
or made to get knocked down well I agree
but I think if he's also made to look
completely just silly what if Francis
wins he ain't gonna win but what if he
CGH it'll be the biggest thing for him
and he'll be in the UFC oh it be the
biggest upset in Combat Sports history
Tyson's the best ever do it at best ever
put on gloves nobody's better if he gets
knocked out by an MMA guy who's never
boxed the rematch money would be
crazy what's interesting there's no
rematch CLA Fury hates rematch CLA so
they Ariel's asking me he like why no
rematch CLA and Tyson like he's like
that's so stupid he's like it takes away
the hype from the the first fight CU
they're like oh if he loses we know
what's next so he's like so i' never do
it he was like that's why the usyk fight
got held up usyk's like we have to have
a rematch closet and he's like no if the
fight's good the fans are want to see it
we don't have to if they know it's
guaranteed then it takes away from the
same with Wilder stuff like that got so
boring like it was so exciting at the
start and then just like rematch rematch
just like it
sucks makes you forget the first fight
even happen agree yeah what else you got
Jen all right this made headlines
recently too so UFC and Bud Light are
now partnering up for like a six-year
deal and you know ever since the
controversy with Bud Light and promoting
thing Bud Light could do they must have
backed up the Brinks truck to get in
with the well so budlight just for some
context wait hold was budlight do you
guys know the budl uh controversy did
was it going ages ago but I can't
remember an American it's always been an
American like sort of standby go it's
just what what what what Bros drink when
they're watching sports Etc and uh they
sponsored Dylan Mulaney who is a
transgender female and everybody was
like really like the transgender get the
[__] out of here with this and it
creates such such a backlash that they
had to close down three breweries that
make Bud Light I don't know if you know
wow three brw and they don't know how to
get it back they couldn't get it back
dude people at my uh at my
shows would like I was I was going to
take a picture with these guys and they
all they had their hands behind their
back and I'm always like who and there's
like six dudes after one of my shows I'm
like what are you guys doing he's like H
don't make fun of us man I'm like what
he's like all they had was Bud Light I'm
like I don't give a [__] is that serious
dude I was at a baseball game with my
with my brother and he wanted to bear
and I was they you order electronically
and we were at the Padre's game and it
said like Modello Kors light they're all
like 18 bucks Bud Light $7 and when I
ordered the bear the guy came by go hey
bro real quick anybody ordering Bud
Lights he goes not one not one he goes
that's how bad
CRA Amic like of of the traditional you
know it's like it was it was like if you
guys think that we are behind you guys
being sponsored by this person who is
deciding they're a woman it was it it
rubbed everybody it was that and then
also if you drink when you you crave
[__] that that that is the that was the
biggest issue that's what I've heard
okay interesting great I'm sorry guys
for his bigotry I've got to get out of
here because I can't because I can't but
how smart are the Bud Light to be like
the most manly sport in the world like
we want to be on the octagon and I bet
Dana was like cool here's the amount and
they're like say less we yeah yeah yeah
cuz that's aneer Bush they own
everything right so anheiser Bush owns
everything but that is the one that was
their state that was such a popular beer
and three breweries that that's another
thing like uh you guys take over here
like loyalty and like patriotism and
everything like really seriously we
don't give a
[__] UK such a Melting Pot it really
really is and there really is less and
you guys would speak on this way more
but there really is I feel less quote
unquote entrenched racism in general I'm
not saying but the the US has has this
Legacy of slavery it's really T so I'm
on stage and I bring up if I bring up
something like I was I had this joke
about being a little bit racist because
I was playing pickup basketball and I
went with the there was there my friend
who's Kore yeah but there's a guy who
Korean who I'd known and there was a
random black guy and I chose the random
black guy you know and but but we won
when I say that it doesn't matter what
audience it gets quiet as [__] it's all
tight like tight tight anything you say
anytime you mention race anytime you
mention I think it's the climate now
like from 2020 I think you're right to
now like Americans have always been they
don't know to laugh or not yeah we
Britain's Britain's has always been a
little bit Yeah so like I remember since
we like recently or not even recently
last couple years I would get a lot of
uh messages of people saying like oh um
thinking about you moving to the UK
we're an interracial couple um I don't
know how it's going to go down over
there like what other like what can I
cuz I'm I'm mixed race myself um they're
like I I don't really know how to
navigate it is there any places I should
stay away from I was like I I don't
understand what do you mean
yeah cuz I'm I'm at being my age I
remember in the in the 80s 90s where it
was it was common place in in Britain
like interracial relationships were what
it was a thing the US was you know in
the 80s and 90s it was still a it was
still a taboo like not taboo but H
interesting you know and say but yeah
and by the way and another issue that
people never talk about is when you were
mixed race in this country and to an
extent not that's gone but to an extent
for a long time up until about 15
minutes ago when you were like a mixed
race and you especially if you were
black finding your place in a black
community as somebody who had a white
father and a wife that was dicey till
Drake came along yeah yeah told Drake
but there was that idea that that was a
whole issue yeah I remember growing up
they used to uh I don't know what
channel it was would have been on here
but we have used to have a a channel
called trouble yeah and it would have um
H what was the what was the so it would
always have like my wife and kids on it
it was a show called oneon-one I think
it was yeah yeah yeah yeah ANZ ANZ and
Ares was mixed race and they would
always bully him for being mixed race
and I didn't understand like it wasn't
it's not a thing yeah um in the UK so
they like oh he's only half black like
don't listen to him and I'm like [__] is
this doesn't get it doesn't it doesn't
like in the UK If you're like mix race
you're seen as black yeah it's not
you're not considered half white you're
just black right um so yeah seeing that
was like damn this is really weird and I
remember going to um Disneyland in
Florida years ago and some guy pulled me
to the side and was I was with my dad
and my stepmom um not the interracial
couple and then the guy pulled me as
side and was like oh you guys are
British like how do how does this go
like how does this relationship go like
what yeah I like someone pulled you
aside yeah it was some black guy was
like it was a black guy was like oh does
he have any like you guys have any
trouble over there I was like what are
you talking about Disneyland trying get
on
Splash correct me if I'm in London in
London in London like in Paris there are
entire neighborhoods that for example
are Arabic you know what I mean like you
so you'll be walking down London and
you'll have like the majority of women
are hijabs it's crazy so it's but I
didn't realize that thing either being
mixed then I saw some uh singer she she
was so hot but
they call her yellow bone and then she
was just getting like brutally like
hated on for being yellow bone I I don't
there a whole about that yeah she was
I'm like
what yeah yes
yep this was a huge thing her she's
[__] I've never seen this
beautiful Chris Brown she was dating the
the baby yeah she had a baby with the
baby I think look at her bring that up
just look at her right there right there
that is a special picture [__] you she's
got kid with the baby I think good God
that's that's ridiculous and she can
sing come on man I love my wife I love
my wife I love my wife I love my wife
yeah she's stupid and Chris Brown of
course yeah decent good for her you
bring up all the I want to see never
mind no more the worst pictures uh yeah
so sonaz has one
here okay I got a little throwback and a
little Seinfeld action um so again in
this country we sue people when our
coffee is too hot cool so this woman is
literally suing Dunkin Donuts right now
because the coffee was too hot she got 3
million she spilled it but it gave her
like third degree burns on her thighs
well it's coffee but third degree but
some even at Starbucks like when I order
a coffee I'm like who's this for it's
[__] lava man like I I got to wait 40
minutes to drink this [__] what are we
doing here and when my dad he's like can
you make it extra hot I'm like what's
wrong with extra hot what the [__] is
wrong with you that was boiled bro
boiling is just boiling I didn't know
there was another stage 100° there's a
level yeah [__] robots I don't know
who going drink yeah you guys have a mad
Sue culture right yeah it's [__] guns
and then suing like that's
American in what was it in the parking
lot the other day and Jacob was trying
to drive through and the the pillars
were like so close so he asked the
security like oh can you help me gauge
if I can go through and go like
nah I don't want any of this please I
need your help he's like he's like I
want that trouble hell if you're on a
plane and you need an aspirin you're not
getting aspirin they're not going to
give you aspirin they won't even give
you aspirin really at a hotel you have
to buy it because they could be like
remember we were talking about that dude
no I don't know how to read things I
what happened usually come on front of
my friends man front of my friends man
you pull your hand be cool man um
remember talking about that dude on the
plane that tried taking over and he was
like put the stops on the airplane when
I told you was tripping he was on
shrooms oh [__] called it yep Oh dude he
got into the cockpit yeah and then he he
was a pilot himself and he was going to
put it in park like in in
the turn the off people on the or
something yeah oh [__] you can't do
mushrooms like that yeah I'm tell been
you Brian didn't he say was he on
mushrooms I said that I was like there
he just wasn't going up there trying to
stop it he was tripping out my friend
called me and said on Rogan he goes hey
dude you're on Rogan do yourself a favor
don't rub your beard beard for 20
minutes and say nothing apparently for
20 minutes doing this I you said cuz
Eddie was freaking me out you know when
you're on mus you guys don't know I was
trying to rip us Bri to get them and he
was like oh man I was like give me
something dude yeah I'm like trying to
keep up cuz Eddie was talking fast and
using his hands a lot so I was like I
can't handle this right now I would have
a panic attack I see that's why I can't
I can't dabble dable in those the
devil's yeah yeah the devil's are black
magic I dark arts I don't get downan was
laughing so hard I talked to him
yesterday he like you took too many I'm
like you could have told me that they're
that strong I feel like you're old
enough to figured out though you well no
cuz he's [__] Fair it's not like he's
some young kid like ah man what are you
doing if Rogan gives you something just
know it's the yeah I don't have
any off for it yeah I wanted it because
I was like let me let me just I just
want a little bit just to see what
happened what say what happened you're
crustation I don't have a backbone I
thought you said you're crushed don't
say it don't say I thought you said
something else what do you think I said
crushed something yeah I crushed yeah
you can put two and two together I
thought it was like a play on
suppression I was like yeah dude Asian
that would be weird what is that dude
knows say anything some American tur
yeah I dress up like an Asian I have
people pile on it's called
CR
yeah I see how you guys get
there get get on me all right cool what
else you
got can't believe your lady over there
just covered her face I apolog she not
your lady but your manager she thinks
this is a PE absolute nightmare she's
having a horrible time that's her job so
apologize I told you this is where we go
you guys started it um what were we
talking about mushrooms all right moving
on what's this Jen so this is a it's a
very popular Instagram handle called
tons of national parks which means Turon
is like a tourist [__] so this guy is
next to a a giant freaking moose and
I'll just play the video for you biggest
animal in the they were so stupid man
they do this in National Park over here
all the time so dumb dude oh my God go
away oh my
God that's a
lady no it's a man it's a it's a dude
you can tell he's an [__] by the
Way's oh he's getting closer but watch
what happens when the Moose he's from
Japan and he's um oh
Jesus he act the way he did the right
thing he gave up ass first well it's not
necessarily the
it's not the right thing cuz a lot of
times you get trampled that's that's
people have died that way oh he got
lucky though but I mean he's so stupid
there's so many stupid people at these
who are you doing it for the gr to walk
up to a grown ass moose I get I go under
you go under and you grab the you grab
the uh neck and you do this and you hold
on like that and you go sh where did you
learn that Brian Jiu-Jitsu yeah bro
train and I'm not I'm not a triple white
out you know what I'm saying be be
honest that's [__] a little
impressive sorry I can't see mic the arm
of this is covering your
[Laughter]
entire have small arms Small Arms
Brian's like C with the Frog shut up
that's not true I have legs tight jeans
these jeans are way too tight for me man
what do you got chin [__] hurting uh
give us one more okay oh let's you want
to do the I don't want it to if you got
two good ones give me that oh here's SAS
okay well in light of Our Guest I
figured we go a little UK for this one
um I don't know about you all but you
guys to watch your spinach in the UK cuz
this woman found a frog in her bag of
spinach damn oh my God that's crazy in
the that's I was going to say that's the
lawsuit no no no it's not because if you
scroll down the Center for Disease
Control actually said sometimes raw
fruits and vegetables contain harmful
germs that can make you and your family
sick such as salmonella ecoi and leria
so that is their get out of jail free
card yeah like we warned you or frogs
Yeah and she didn't notice
it with the cream sauce she got all the
way through it yeah she did by the way
she mixed it up yeah and I'm smelling I
I'm a little suspect I got I got
skeptical hit we've seen that before
yeah they try to sue them right I don't
buy it I don't buy it cuz the way they
wash those things the way the way they
process you're not getting a c frog in
there yeah but but now it's on there do
she toss it It's too convenient crazy
that's disgusting I remember yeah when
years ago I bought like a pack of like
bell peppers and I opened it up and it
had like four caterpillars inside it no
yeah so I rang up the supermarket and
they were like bro it's organic like
it's your problem organic yeah it's
organic like you should they're
caterpillars
[__] [__] my buddy what do you want us
to do my buddy he bit in the chicken and
he broke his tooth oh Trader Joe's there
was glass in the chicken I don't know
how but there's it's a thing they had
they had an issue with it like five
months before that so I have a friend
who's a lawyer he calls my friend he and
I remember he he was he was a my he's a
trainer got that and uh and he cracked
his literally broke his tooth and he was
like I'm going to make I'm going to make
a million dollars off this [__] like I'm
gonna make all the money so he hires my
friend is the lawyer so funny he goes he
goes uh I had to go to the dentist and
everything I got pictures and lur goes
so what do you want to do and he goes I
want to make you know I mean they owe me
money and my friend is Laur goes what do
you think you're going to make he goes I
don't know man this feels like a sixf
figured thing seven he goes you're going
to make they'll pay you maybe
maybe 12 Grand but I think it'll be
closer to n grand for your Dentistry if
we push him oh Dam and yeah so you don't
they just they know this stuff is going
to happen like you're not unless unless
you find a human finger in there and
they can prove it you're you're not
gonna I don't know why I told you that
story a build up you know when you're
telling a story and you're like [__] I
got to come up with something better
make some's got to die there's got to be
a car chase in this and then nothing he
got on his phone during your
I wish I was him well you telling him
like oh man we have friends here I
respect your bravery though dude thank
you buddy I appreciate shoot I know I
can I can always count on you anything
else chin that's it [__] is this it's so
disrespectful so no uh US tour announced
dates right
now none of our um tour days for next
year being um announced yet um but got
some big ones it should be good um
yeah I need to gossip about it I not we
haven't told anyone so after the cameras
I'll tell you what we're
playing but I need to gossip but um yeah
nothing nothing nothing um locked in yet
announc got some good restaurants lined
up you going to eat you guys Foodies
yeah we our food where did we go the
other day catch catch is great catch is
great that's a scene too Mar catch is
scene too marij marir was good food
yesterday at top of a hotel we got some
we got some recommendations I went to
last time we went to one of your
recommendations though scopa SC was
great that was good theand was amazing
absolutely I love that you guys listen I
love that [__] you guys are making some
good starts yeah man it's been it's been
good so far jet lag has killed me I'm
okay today I had I had a 10:30 7:30
sleep so I was great mess I've been
waking up at like 4:00 a.m. every day
got to take naps unfortunately like it's
brutal but n we've had a good time man
this has been we know you guys are busy
man we're we're fans over here fans keep
on trucking fellas the best apprciate
you gang
[__]